if you're someone with ambition that
wants more out of life then you're
probably
pretty lonely trust me i've been there
even though i had many friends in high
school
i always felt like an outsider and it
only got worse once i started wanting to
improve my life i read books about
meditation stopped drinking alcohol
started setting goals for myself but
none of my friends were on the same
wavelength the things i was extremely
passionate about i couldn't really share
with any of them i didn't want to be
that kid that just like hey guys
have you heard of meditation so i kept
it all to myself
and it felt like nobody knew who i truly
was it was like
i was living a double life and i would
say this is stage one of
going through this loneliness cycle as
someone with ambition
you hear the call for more where your
path is
splitting itself from everyone else's
but it got really bad when i started my
first business
i was in a new city working all by
myself all day and just
craving any form of social interaction
but every time i hung out with the
friends of my girlfriend at the time or
just
normal people i only felt more isolated
so after a while i just
stopped trying because even though i was
experiencing this
crippling loneliness it was easier than
spending time with people that just
didn't get me and this is where i got
into stage two
i started accepting my fate as a lone
wolf
and at that point i understood where
that feeling of
being alone in a crowded room comes from
you'll feel this every time you think
you need to filter yourself in order to
fit in or be accepted
but in this stage there's one source of
connection you do have
welcome to impact theory our goal with
this show you can make some decisions
to adjust that and over the next because
it's from nothing and
he grew to two billion every minute i
wasn't working
i was listening to someone who inspired
me who understood me
whether it was a podcast or an audiobook
or just
some random guy on youtube with a funny
accent that has an
abnormally large forehead and i had
these
imaginary relationships with these
people online that helped me keep my
sanity at the time but it was only a
temporary band-aid for a broken leg
after a while i just couldn't keep going
like this and i just had to
figure out how to make some friends but
there was only one problem
i sucked at making friends just in
general people
suck at making new friends because they
never actually have to proactively do it
just look at your life right now i bet
that 90 of the people that you know
you just happened to meet by accident
they were at your school that you went
to
at the university you went to or just at
work you were just put into an
environment where it just happens
but this time i was working by myself i
had my own business i was working from
home
[Music]
i had to put myself in an environment
where these people hang out which
brought me to the next stage
the lone wolf looking for a new pack i
went on meetup.com and set a goal to go
to two meetups
every week of course i couldn't just go
i had to set a goal
i went wherever i could find people who
were interested in bringing their career
or life to the next level and that's
exactly
who i met people who were interested
in doing that at some point everywhere i
went it was the same
they were curious about starting a
business but the moment i told them that
i was already doing well in business at
the time i was making like 100k in
revenue per month you could see
something
shift in their eyes they started
drilling me with all these questions and
it felt like they were putting me on a
pedestal and were extra nice to me to
like pick my brain but i was just some
dude who
came here to pick some friends so then i
started my own meetup where the
requirement to join was that you have to
have an up and running business
guess how many people showed up
[Music]
zero no one there's a bunch of people
that came to the events but they were
all
just thinking of starting out at some
point i ended up being the one that
everyone looked up to because i actually
had a business and i hate that feeling i
don't want anyone to look up to me
i'm just a dude at that point i started
becoming a little bitter
this idea that the higher you climb the
longer it gets
i thought maybe there's something to it
was it worth it to climb to the top if
you're gonna end up lonely and this
stage is called
the lone wolf tried joining a new pack
with the same interest but now it's
looking for a pack that is on the path
to climbing
higher mountains i don't know i'm just
making up these stages to
sound smart and like i know what i'm
talking about which of course i do
because
i'm someone on the internet and this is
when i was uh let down the wrong path
because i started thinking maybe i can
only really connect with people if
they're on a similar level in business
or
higher up whatever that means and i
ended up paying 15
000 for a year-long membership to join a
community of
advanced entrepreneurs in sydney but i
thought if i just meet one person that
is on a similar level that i can connect
with
this will be worth it and i actually
ended up meeting a couple of
heavy hitters you know people that were
running multiple companies with dozens
of employees
it was great the conversations were
really interesting and we were able to
connect intellectually
but something was still off these were
not really
people that i could be friends with and
that's when my mind
started to shift i'm still going to meet
ups at the time and i
ended up meeting these couple of young
guys who were just really
cool they were running a little business
on the side nothing huge they were fun
to talk to we had very similar interests
and we could talk about things we're
passionate about and this time it just
clicked but what was different this time
and this stage is called
i don't know something where the lone
wolf doesn't look for a pack that's just
kind of the biggest mountain brother
that likes pointing out as well it's
also just really cool
he clicks with i've run out of analogies
but there's one that i've heard that
explains it really really well there's
three types of friends
first there's beer friends we've all
been around those before
these are the types of friends that you
can have fun with they're funny you can
go out with them but if you're looking
for a deep connection or
a meaningful conversation about your
crazy business idea or
pokemon collection then you're gonna be
disappointed then
there's wine friends these are friends
who not just have similar interests but
people you can have really
deep meaningful and stimulating
conversations with about the stuff that
you care about
they help you grow and learn new things
and challenge your views
and these were some of the people that i
met in this exclusive
entrepreneur group that i joined but
what i really wanted all this time
was whiskey friends they don't have to
be irish though they can just be from
anywhere
they're not just fun you can also have
deep conversations with them but most
importantly you can share your most
vulnerable moments with them
go through thick and thin you have their
back and they have yours
why are you able to do that with them
because you have matching values with
them
not necessarily the same but you have
aligning values
by meeting these two guys i had gotten
my foot in the door because soon after
we each met some more people who were
also on the same wavelength we added
them to the group
and that's the final stage which is when
you're building your own
wolf pack after a while we had an entire
group of like-minded people who were
excited about growth
we hung out worked together traveled and
played pranked on each other but this
didn't last very long
if you've seen my previous video about
how i built and sold my first business
then maybe you know why
long story short my relationship ended
which terminated my visa and i had to
leave australia and what fallout was one
of the loneliest years of my life i saw
my friends in australia post pictures
together on social media and i was
living all by myself and this tiny
studio apartment in germany was rainy
and gray
and all this made me realize a very sad
truth about relationships they can be
very hard to find
especially for weirdos like us they take
a long time to build and the more time
is invested the better they usually get
and when they split apart
it is a huge loss in your life
but all the effort it takes it's worth
it
so i decided to this time really do
something about it
i wanted to put myself in a situation
where i have an abundance of
relationships no matter where i go
i have someone to go to i just started
posting into different facebook groups
and connecting with the people that i
thought might be interesting and i
scheduled calls with a bunch of people
from all over the world
and the few that i really clicked with
they all told me they were also
experiencing this loneliness
well it was really hard for them to meet
like-minded people one of them was a
german guy who was living in cyprus
another one in bali then there was
a guy from new zealand a couple of
australians and us americans and i
organized these weekly
group calls to just chat and exchange
ideas which ended up becoming a
highlight for
most of the people in the group it was
still pretty lonely because it was
just behind the laptop screen but slowly
one thing started leading to the next
while living in barcelona i met up with
one of the guys who i connected with
online and we just
became friends very quickly he
introduced me to a couple of other
people who
then later on we ended up going to an
event with in croatia where
people from all over the world that were
entrepreneurial came together and there
i made more friends
then i was visiting some guys from my
online group who were living in cyprus
the
european tax haven and slowly but surely
i started
building out a wide network of people an
ecosystem of like-minded people
and this brought me to the place where i
am now i have friends all over the world
in different countries that i'm still in
touch with i live in a house with three
lovely roommates who are entrepreneurial
and
super fun and i don't experience that
same type of loneliness anymore
if you are struggling to meet
like-minded people here's what i think
you should do
first understand that you're currently
here on this curve
it starts with just meeting that one
person who then might know another and
that person might know an entire group
until you're building your own ecosystem
that grows
exponentially it is so much easier to
meet new people when you've already met
some people who are on the same
wavelength and remember that you can
only really connect with people
if you are really being yourself and
you're not filtering yourself to be
accepted or fit in secondly make it a
weekly or monthly routine that you
schedule to build a nurture
relationships we all do it with our
health by
working out three times a week but
nobody really does it for their
relationships even though that's the
biggest pillar that determines whether
you live a happy and fulfilling life or
not
whether it's just calling a friend who
you haven't spoken to in a while every
week going to a meet-up or every month
just setting up your own dinner where
you invite new people to your place
these routines are really important
and it's actually something i need to do
more of and when it comes to putting
yourself out there
look up events that are put together by
online communities that you're part of
or just
some people that you like that are
making content i see content in
everything
because what i found is that the people
that you really click with oftentimes
just consume the same stuff as you and
that's why they have similar interests
and
matching values and that's my goal for
the channel i want to
rebrand this into a movement that can
bring some lone wolves together and also
with multiple creators not just
with me and my face on it because i
don't want it to be about me i want this
to be a group
and if one day i hear that people have
met their best friends through an event
that we've put together this will be one
of my proudest achievements because in
the end
life is all about the experiences you
have with people you love
if you want to know how i built and sold
my first business then you can check out
this video over here where i laid out
the full story
i'll see you over there and thanks for
watching i hope this helped
[Music]